Oh someone soaps that they can't come to
the Streamy Awards with me do you want
to come to the Streamy Awards would you
be my date would you hold my hands would
you say oh I think that I found myself a
cheerleader Jenna will be here in a
second and she will take good care of
you and I'm often Streamy Awards I'm
excited this is like the fifth streamys
which I can't believe it it's oh my gosh
she breaks my heart I want to take him
with me I want to take you everywhere
but I can't so see you guys right here
here we go Ted about to go online
I want you got the clap I want you to
cheer what you go crazy
I just
we are you're doing this crazy
we're all crazy my team thank you to you
guys
I'm speechless
hey Sela streamys are over I don't even
know what I filmed there I'm not even
sure but I'm gonna probably get
emotional I really don't cry don't cry
tonight was really crazy because seeing
how far the Internet has come since the
very very beginning of sort of me
starting my youtube channel and creating
content I mean there's so many people
doing it so now it's one of those things
where everybody is doing it like if you
don't have YouTube channel it's like I'm
sorry you don't meet YouTube channel why
I don't understand the back when I first
started doing this stuff no one had
YouTube channels no one was on Twitter
no one was using these sort of new crazy
tools and platforms to I don't I wasn't
even promoting myself I was just I was
more or less just bored and and having
fun and connecting with people and I
think that is you know that's where it
all started I've always loved connecting
with people but it's interesting because
what a lot of people don't know is I am
extremely introverted so for me to sort
of even put myself out there as much as
I do and I know a lot of my other
youtube friends are the same exact way a
lot of us are introverts so for us to be
able to sit here and talk to a camera
that's easy we're sitting here not
talking to anyone but we're talking to
someone we're talking to a lot of people
not really sure where I'm going with
this because I'm rambling but tonight I
want to Streamy and it's insane to sort
of have been at every Streamy Awards
since it first started I think it was
the fifth one and it's just I'm just so
proud of the community and I'm proud of
all of my friends and you guys for I
don't know I mean I know so many of you
guys started out just watching us make
crazy videos and you started making
crazy videos and it's just really cool
to see how huge and amazing that this
community has become and I'm just so
honored and flattered and
really happy that that I am a part of it
and that you guys are all a part of it I
don't know what I'm saying either way
all of this is just one huge big thank
you just thank you
for just letting me be myself thank you
for I think I tweeted this no I don't
think I did I know I tweeted it I said
thank you for letting me live my dreams
and not just me all of my YouTube
friends as well because this is
something that never existed it was not
a career path now people are choosing to
become youtubers and that's weird and
that's crazy but that is a reality and
it's not just YouTube there's snapchat
or there's Viners there's so many
different ways that you can just express
yourself and it's amazing and I love you
guys so much honestly I I went up there
today and I was completely speechless I
really honestly was and that's something
that never usually happens
I don't ever not have something to say
even a lot of times when I'm saying
things it's just a bunch of random words
that I somehow string together to make
sense of it but I actually really had
nothing to say today and I was I on that
stage like boom what do I say anyway
thank you guys again I cannot ever thank
you enough for just being so amazing and
so supportive through all these years
because a lot of you guys I know have
been there from the beginning some of
you may have just started watching today
some of you may have been here you know
only maybe for a week but doesn't matter
what matters is you're awesome and I
love you and thank you um yeah I'm gonna
go to bed now cuz I have a dentist
appointment in the morning that's why
I'm not out partying with the rest of
the crew at the Streamy Awards
after-party because I've got to go to
the dentist so that's it I love you
thank you so much are you excited about
your first shoot what about your bag I
think he's gonna be real into it